with 500 million monthly users Spotify
is the world's largest music streaming
service
Spotify is the home of audio
it's known for its personalized
playlists made with its recommendation
algorithm think about users as this raw
material and then on top of the data
layer we're able to build shared models
but relying so much on artificial
intelligence has also drawn criticism
from some industry experts worried about
algorithmic bias here's how Spotify uses
AI to personalize users experiences on
the platform
this is the tech behind Spotify
in the early 2000s many people found
music recommendations through top charts
and early streaming platforms like
Pandora and Last FM with the Last FM app
from the App Store you can listen to
Great bands so when Spotify entered the
scene in 2008 it's not so much that
they're the first people to start using
analytics to recommend music but it was
the way in which they combined various
computational techniques in order to
make their recommendations feel more
lifelike Thomas Hodgson studies
algorithms and artificial intelligence
with a focus on how new technology from
music streaming companies impact artists
fans who have listened to discover
weekly and daily mix the way that they
talk about them is in very human-like
terms discover weekly you magnificent
you've done it again in 2014 Spotify
acquired music analytics from the echo
Nest which Blended machine learning and
natural language processing to build a
database of songs and artists Spotify
says this technology marked an important
step in the evolution of its
recommendation system
how does that system work it starts with
a process called collaborative filtering
collaborative filtering looks at the
pattern across all of this data and
tries to understand when do tracks
happen to be playlisted together very
often you can think of it as building a
map of music and podcasts that map looks
something like this each point
represents a different track in
spotify's catalog and the location of
each point is determined by
collaborative filtering which means that
these tracks go together
according to the way users have
playlisted them and listened to them so
if these two songs are frequently
playlisted together they will be close
to each other in this map whereas if
these songs are never playlisted
together they will be farther apart in
the map but recommendations based purely
on collaborative filtering aren't
perfect for example during the holidays
Mariah carries All I Want For Christmas
Is You might get playlisted more
frequently with silent night even though
this sounds like a pop song
[Music]
foreign
if Spotify only generated
recommendations based on proximity then
users who like Mariah Carey might get
recommended Silent Night when they
aren't interested in Christmas carols
to prevent this Spotify adds another
layer of analysis called content-based
filtering this algorithm gathers
metadata like the release date and label
and executes a raw audio analysis it
uses metrics like dance ability and
loudness to describe the Sonic
characteristics of the track these are
the results for Uptown Funk which sounds
like this
[Music]
it has a dance ability score of 0.856 on
a scale of 0 to 1. the algorithm also
dissects each track's temporal structure
here's a visual representation of that
for anti-hero by Taylor Swift these are
the Beats the bars and the sections
content-based filtering also takes into
account attracts cultural context which
means studying the lyrics and analyzing
the adjectives used to describe the
track in articles and blogs these
filtering techniques are not unique to
Spotify but industry experts say what
sets the platform apart is the amount of
user data it has and the products it
creates from it Spotify says it's
content-based filtering technology has
evolved over the years and now includes
more advanced proprietary facing
features
but Hodgson says the danger with
algorithms is that they could reinforce
existing biases this could mean that a
particular catalog of music has more
male artists than female artists one of
the dangers with machine learning is
that as listeners start to engage with
that catalog those biases become
magnified and that this creates what's
called a kind of feedback loop Spotify
says its research teams evaluate and
mitigate against potential algorithmic
inequities and harms and strive for
transparency about its impact another
criticism is that the algorithm isn't
optimized for new artists because
there's no user data this is known as
the cold start problem Sultan says this
is where human editors play a
significant role in delivering
recommendations is there possibly some
of the best people in the world and
trying to understand new releases and
culture and what's relevant but Hodgson
says the bigger concern is that certain
metrics used in the platform's audio
analysis might be culturally biased in
other parts of the world they have
musical systems and musical cultures
that are entirely different like this
North Indian classical track for example
spotify's algorithm labels its key
signature as E minor which Hodgson says
is inappropriate for this musical
tradition however it's still the case
that the music that is emerging from
South Asia is being understood
algorithmically under you know the
Western equal temperament scale Spotify
says the audio analysis is one small
part of the overall system which takes
into account many factors before making
a recommendation
some industry experts also point to
issues with how the system understands
metadata for classical music for example
the metadata for our Tchaikovsky truck
can include not just the name of the
work and the artist but also the
movement Opus number and conductor
spotify's algorithm isn't optimized for
that Apple music which has emerged in
recent years as a competitor to Spotify
released a new app in March that the
company says is designed to solve this
problem
[Music]
Spotify says it doesn't comment on a
competitor's marketing campaigns in
February the streaming service joined
the recent Buzz around generative AI I'm
X and from this moment on I'm going to
be your own personal AI DJ on Spotify
the DJ gives the algorithm a human voice
and offers listeners additional context
around a recommendation
up next I know you've been on a summer
song kick lately Sultan says the company
is also exploring reinforcement learning
a technique that would allow the
recommendation system to learn
automatically based on feedback it will
help with the diversity of their
recommendation it will help with the
longer term retention and we're trying
to push the state of the Arts in each of
those introducing new technologies new
capabilities and bringing new
experiences
foreign